j'ai su que j'étais une fille ne re la
maternelle s'est pas dit à ma main et tu
as dis à personne
non tu la garder pour toi tu aimes pas
dit à tes copines à tes copains ladi 6
mois avant nous avant de nous le dira
nous six mois avant elle a annoncé à un
copain comme un copain comme un appel
elle dormait chez un pote et elle lui a
dit mais on a appris que très tard c'est
avec elle que tu as dit je suis pas un
garçon je suis une fille et pourquoi
comment tu ressentais ça parce que c'est
c'est si c'est intéressant de savoir
comment tu comment tu l'a ressenti c'est
pas facile à expliquer puisque ce que tu
as cuite on est tu l'a ressenti à quel
âge auras de 4,5 en trois 3 ans ah ouais
et commencer comment ça se passe comment
ça c'est en fait je pense qu'elle était
elle s'est rendu compte de ça de son
mal-être vers 3 ans à l'entrée à l'école
d'accord mais je pense que depuis
toujours elle s'identifier comme une
fille en fait non le vois mal an a
posteriori son positionnement par
rapport à son frère et sa soeur elle
s'est toujours vécu comme une fille et
si à l'école qu'elle a pris conscience
que bell n'était pas n'était pas ce
genre et comme il fallait et que ça lui
convenait pas du tout les groupes dans
lesquels elle allait donc elle a
commencé chez j jeune âge elles sont qu'
elle n'était pas sa place rentré dans
une classe de 2e année de maternelle et
demandez-leur les filles d'un côté des
garçons de l'autre n'a pas un qui se
trompent demande c'est intimidant depuis
le plus jeune âge il y met jamais le
souvenir d'avoir été un gars enfin il il
se mettait côté sauter défini et donc
mais mais j'aurais clairement moi
comment comment tu te sens tu es pro tu
te sentais pas bien estelle vous en
parler à vous disais quoi quand elle a
commencé à montrer comment elle a
commencé à sentir très très mal l'année
de ses six ans ouais et on en a parlé
vous a dit quoi
quand elle m'en a parlé et m'a dit
qu'elle ne voulait plus de tous ces
attributs masculins
elle n'a pas utilisé ce mot là elle a
dit qu'elle ne voulait plus et voulait
changer son prénom elle voulait plus de
ses cheveux courts militaire et elle
voulait plus de son pénis d'accord
pourquoi pourquoi que le sel et ben
parce que c'est dur pour une fille
d'avoir un pénis et chats elle chantait
pas ça me tire à ses samples voix pour
toi t'es tu es tu étais pas ta place
ce qui la rendait malheureux
ça c'est le fait de voir grandir sa
grande soeur aussi que s'épanouit comme
une petite jeune fille est de voir ses
cousins et son frère qui vendre dans la
voie où son corps va et du coup je pense
qu est ce qu il a mis très très mal
l'année avant cannes nous en parle c'est
justement la difficulté qu'elle a eu à
nous en parler
savais pas du tout comment ça allait
être pressée ça et puis et puis nous on
était forcément hyper inquiet parce
qu'une enfants de 6 ou 7 1 qui explique
toutes les façons dont elle avait pensé
pour se tuer face tf1 croit parce que je
sais qu'elle a et c est dingue de penser
ça à ton jeune âge tu as traversé une
période de dépression mali qu'est ce que
tu me paraît que tu voulais plus vivre
comme ça c'est dur a évoqué pour elle
cette période là parce que en fait le
corps humain il est très bien fait et la
période de latence qu'elle est en train
de de traverser lui permet d'oublier les
mauvais souvenirs c'est comme ça qu'on
se construit tous en fête en garde le
meilleur donc là en train d'oublier tout
doucement cette phase nous on met des
choses factuelles de côté pour que le
jour où elles veulent s'y replonger elle
puisse avoir son histoire de façon la
plus objective possible mais mais oui du
coup je te rappel de ces soirées là où
c'était dur je restais longtemps près du
lit ça va mieux maintenant lily ce que
je te sens en pleine forme lâche 200
euros pourtant fertile et elle aurait pu
non mais c'est vrai nord depuis la
station heureuse tu te sens à ta place
la théorie